hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 11th 2019 what is going
on with you how are you um I am actually
recording part of this anyways I'll be
recording here Saturday night because
I'm out here Turin doing a little bit of
stand-up and just when I have to fly on
Sunday and then I got a [ __ ] bunch of
[ __ ] I have to do Monday I got it I got
to do this in spurts they got to do a
couple of rounds here you know it's
weird I've been walking around today all
by myself all by my lonesome and for
some reason I don't know why this
[ __ ] melody with the wrong lyrics has
been stuck in my head I just been
walking around going Sherry's berries
why you buggin makes no [ __ ] sense
whatsoever
I never had a son I always had a song
for me on these B undies so if Sheree's
berries keeps that they might advertise
this [ __ ] week I have no idea I'm
doing this so early I don't even have
the advertising yet you understand you
understand how dangerous the podcast
this is right now anyways
anyway against as I've been told I'm
supposed to say instead anyways anyway
I'm [ __ ] I did my first stand-up Road
gig and since I came back from Europe
ended the acting gig and I walked out on
stage got on the [ __ ] bicycle and it
was was alright everything went great I
want to thank everybody came out to the
Borgata in Atlantic City I had a great
[ __ ] time and now I'm sort of
barnstorming around just doing some like
you know clubs and local areas and [ __ ]
just doing the hour trying to figure out
how I'm gonna put this [ __ ] thing
together Whittle some [ __ ] down get in
get out take this [ __ ] thing and then
move on to my next hour my favorite
[ __ ] thing to do my favorite
[ __ ] thing to do is is that is the
day after the special when all that
material is flushed down the [ __ ]
toilet and I get to start all over again
no [ __ ] pressure you know the
precious tis special don't you get the
special done you know if you like me
you're gonna continue to like [ __ ] up in
life so the material is going to come
you know speaking of [ __ ] up I was
staying in this hotel about a week ago I
forgot to tell you the story what's the
[ __ ] eye I swear to God like the
level of like hostile that corporations
have got to as far as just complete lack
of customer service you can't get
anybody on the [ __ ] phone
total skeleton crew go [ __ ] yourself
the way this this [ __ ] is now you know I
mean like if you have a problem with
your [ __ ] iPhone who the hell are you
gonna call how the [ __ ] you gonna get
anybody on the phone or at least
something from in this [ __ ]
hemisphere you can't do it right so last
couple of hotels I stayed in right I go
to call room service how long should
that take two three [ __ ] rings
worst-case scenario they usually have an
outgoing message going like hey if you
reach this message just leave your room
number and we will we'll call you right
back and we'll figure out what whatever
you want right so a [ __ ] call this
the goddamn thing rings three times puts
me on hold I put it on speaker I'm
sitting there for like 15 [ __ ]
minutes so I hang up like alright so I
[ __ ] call the front desk and I was
like yeah hey I'm trying to order the
Reuben the Reuben sandwich they're right
I can't get through nobody's picking up
still the lady the front desk oh that's
strange here let me let me I'll put you
right through puts me through to the
same extension I'm back on hold again
listening to the same [ __ ] music sit
there again for another 10 minutes now
about 25 minutes into trying to order a
[ __ ] sandwich alright
so then I go I [ __ ] this I go to the
next one I call customer service
there's a customer service button
somebody picks up after three rings I
tell them what the [ __ ] problem is he
said oh my god that's terrible I'm so
sorry mr. burr you know I'll let me let
me get you through I'll stay on with you
right same [ __ ] extension same
[ __ ] on hold music and I'm sitting
there for like 15 seconds and I'm like
wait I'm like dude are you still there
he wasn't there so I [ __ ] call back
customer service again somebody else
picks up I said I tell the whole [ __ ]
story they just told to you it's like
the ninth time I'm telling this story I
feel front desk the [ __ ] third time
right and as I'm telling it she goes he
didn't stay on with you and I'm like no
like is that normal behavior she goes
I'm sorry all right let me get you
through and she finally gets me through
okay it's a room service it rings and
the guy on the other end picks up room
service and just goes hello I'm like
yeah is this room service he's like yeah
I'm like I'd like to order some food to
the room it's like super awkward he goes
all right like okay can I get that
Reuben sandwich he's like yep I go all
right can I get a side salad instead of
the fries is it all right if I get a
salad instead of the fries and he goes
no flat out says no now what am I gonna
do complain to him he's got my food he's
got me by the balls so I was like all
right you know I guess I'm eating fries
he's like well what do you what do you
want to drink I just go let me get a
water with ice see it goes all right so
you know I get in the room number and I
[ __ ] hang up and then I just sit
there walking around my [ __ ] hotel
room muttering to myself going it
literally took me a [ __ ] half-hour
to get through to somebody that could
get me to somebody to order a [ __ ]
sandwich to my room and then when I
asked you know have it your way Burger
King he basically was like yeah no go
[ __ ] it's like I was his kid daddy can
we get some ice cream now all right I
guess you're taller than me and you're
driving and you're paying for everything
so I guess what you say goes this guy's
[ __ ] talking to me like that so now
I'm in another hotel and I wanted to
find out I don't know what there was a
vending machine on this [ __ ] floor
and I'm trying to [ __ ] that there's no
button on the phone that says front desk
and this is feeling like a trend where
I've noticed you know you're going to
your room if there's no menu you call
them up if you can get somebody on the
phone where's the menu they say it's on
your TV and then you go on the TV and
you got to use figure out your [ __ ]
remote control it's all on you you have
to figure it out right and you got to
figure this [ __ ] out and then order it
without talking and anybody like how far
they gonna take this I feel like in the
future like you're gonna be like
especially in this country with the
[ __ ] healthcare you're gonna be like
dying or something and it's gonna be up
to you to figure out like how to get
ahold of somebody and I don't know what
you know if yeah yeah hey I got stabbed
in the abdomen okay yeah it's wondering
if I could get some room service if you
could like driving the ambulance over
here maybe like pick me up all right
yeah can you you know maybe bring like
some bandages and stuff no all right
well the ambulance gonna show up yeah
all right then it's gonna be like like
that level of [ __ ] I don't know my
[ __ ] pet peeve though is people that
hate their [ __ ] job you know what I
mean and then they take it out on you
it's like dude it's not my [ __ ] fault
you work here okay you don't like the
job quit I
had [ __ ] jobs and I [ __ ] I destroyed
you know the [ __ ] are you doing you're
gonna try when you get your dream job
go [ __ ] yourself you're gonna suck the
hole - oh man oh I got another good one
I hope I'm assuming you enjoyed that
story here's another travel story for
you so I'm on my way to Atlantic City
right and I I get on the plane and I'm
sitting there and I just is I'm sitting
there I'm looking down I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing reading a magazine -
some [ __ ] and I was reading Rolling
Stone and hear this guy going bill burr
bill hey bill bill burr hey Bill bill
burr and look up I see it's his comic I
know my god [ __ ] hey how you doing he's
like you working in Philly I was like no
I'm laying in there and I'm gonna
[ __ ] Drive over to Atlantic City goes
out cooler I'll talk to you when we get
off right so I hadn't seen him in a
while I'm not gonna name any names here
because I don't want to get anybody in
[ __ ] trouble right so we get off the
[ __ ] I get off the plane all right
take a leak had come out he's [ __ ]
Stan hey what's going on so we start
shooting the [ __ ] and we're walking and
we get to the you know the moving
sidewalk we hadn't seen each other a
little bit we was standing side by side
but you're not supposed to do because
it's walk or stand so this guy is he's
walking up is going excuse me excuse me
like he only had to say it once and we
immediately immediately got out of the
way and he comes Hough and buys he walks
by then he points up at the sign that
says walk or stand so I just was like I
go hey buddy relax
he's walking he goes you relaxed I go
you're the one pointing at the sign he
started talking more [ __ ] and I go oh
yeah I get it I get it
yeah you got your earbuds in you're
important right so he starts giving me
[ __ ] and I just start saying and turn
around
every now and then I get a little bit
some you know cuz this song he was
listening to and I made him so mad he
gave me the finger and it was like the
highlight of my [ __ ] trip I was
already in a bad mood because the second
we landed some [ __ ] like five rows back
immediately turned on the cellphone and
had like a conversation at the top of
his lungs you know and I know there's
something weird about this we're in that
story than the middle story I was the
[ __ ] because I was standing what you was
supposed to be walking but the thing is
the second the guy said excuse me
I knew what I was doing wrong and I
immediately got out of the [ __ ] way I
didn't act you know immediately got of
the way this guy's still shaking his
[ __ ] head I was just looking at the
guy like who the [ __ ] are you to behave
like me in that situation you know the
nervous some people who you to walk by
mad at me that I wasn't aware that he
would try anything this is a thing he
wasn't really even in a [ __ ] hurry
cuz he had the time to argue with me and
give me the finger
he's just one of those [ __ ] people
that just has to walk fast until they
feel like they're getting somewhere I
don't know by the way I got to tell you
something those stupid little [ __ ]
little half of straws that people have
hanging out of their [ __ ] ears it's
just you know that's like the Bluetooth
of headphones I think very soon people
are gonna it's gonna become like
remember like Bluetooth was cool for
like a week evidently and then everybody
just made fun of that stupid thing
hanging out of your ear I really think
that those whatever those things are
called I have no idea I always looks
like you have a little bit little straw
hanging out of your [ __ ] ear
I'm not a fan of those I've always been
a fan of headphones I don't like my ears
of [ __ ] from playing drums and I don't
like Jam and [ __ ] into my ear I don't
know plus you know what if you have a
gotten like right like thanked right
there what have we gotten to a fight
right me and that guy and I [ __ ]
threw a hook and I punched him right in
the air and then that thing goes in it
was ear you know and then for the rest
of his life he's listening to [ __ ]
blondie hear something in one of his
ears that
get out her punches there's eardrums and
I get sued you know all because I wanted
to say hello to a comic okay do you
understand that people that's how quick
it can happen that's how quickly you can
lose your hearing by the way you know
what's really [ __ ] underrated old
lady card games i sat down with the
relative of mine this past week there
was a deck of cards there right had like
a little family Union thing right and
one of my relatives she's a little bit
older whatever I was just like hey you
uh you want to play gin rummy and she
was like yeah she proceeded to kick my
ass for like the next hour but we
weren't on our smartphones weren't
watching TV weren't doing anything we
were just sitting there you know talking
about the old days laughing having a
good time giving each other [ __ ] trying
to remember how to keep score and I
don't know a guy really got a love
sitting that going like you know that's
one of the coolest hangs I've had with
this particular relative in a long
[ __ ] time I don't know it made me
kind of think like you know what I
should I need to bring that into my life
you know my kid's gonna be hilarious
she's gonna be like totally of this time
and then like know how to drive like a
Ford f-100 three on the tree she's gonna
know how to play old lady card games I
figure it like out all this [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] good from back in the day at
least what I considered I'm gonna teach
her how to do old school [ __ ] like
knowing how to cook as opposed to just
doing the postmates [ __ ] you know you
know whether she wants to do it or
whatever she'll know how to do it you
know what I mean I don't know and maybe
immediately think like what if I just
converted my entire garage into like a
cigar bar and had friends over over we
played cards I
smoke eater so we could smoke inside
then I'm like well I can't [ __ ] do
that because then I'll [ __ ] die of
throat and mouth cancer because it'll
just be two goddamn fun you know what I
mean it's weird it's a really weird
thing being an adult you know and it's
also even more weird figuring it out at
50 does you have that thing when all of
a sudden you know I guess you go away to
college you just move out and you're
like okay my parents aren't here anymore
now I can do whatever the [ __ ] I want
and you do whatever the [ __ ] you want
for a while and then you just start
paying for it and I've kind of been
learning this really at my age there's
nothing better than going to bed sober
and having eight hours of uninterrupted
sleep if I do that and wake up stretch
and then go to the gym I feel like like
15 years younger than I said I feel like
I'm in my 30s like it's [ __ ]
ridiculous now having said that I plan
to go back to booze you know at some
point but I just I got to get through
taping my special and then there's an
outside chance I have another acting gig
coming up and you know cuz you never
know now Jesus Christ you have no
[ __ ] idea
you know used to be back in the day if
you if you were on something this far
into where I'm at with this deal you
were in there but not nowadays you know
one [ __ ] tweet or somebody reads some
[ __ ] from [ __ ] you know somebody
pulls out a yearbook from the 80s I mean
you know you don't know what can happen
you don't know what's in there you don't
you don't know what the [ __ ] other
people have done and all it takes is one
principal [ __ ] person you know
there's some [ __ ] you know VHS tape
of him kicking a pigeon in the [ __ ]
beacon and then the whole [ __ ] thing
goes away so I don't know
so anyways there there is a thing that I
always like you know I've always wanted
to go an entire calendar year January
1st through December 34
and not drink and just be like I didn't
drink that year so I think I think this
might be the year I know it's already
cruising by I'm like [ __ ] 11 weeks in
already you know what's the point of
stopping by the time I take my special
that'll be another three weeks that's 14
weeks 52 weeks in a year 52 minus 14 38
weeks to go I'm Nam I can't make it
through that I think I can do it but
anyways what the [ __ ] else did I want to
talk about I'm actually sitting here now
late night just did a spot and I'm
watching Showtime boxing you know it's
weird I didn't realize HBO
like let go with a box box whoops sorry
boxing after all of these years and then
on top of that Jim Lampley is gone so
they still got that al Bernstein guy or
whatever I don't know who but they got
all these new announcers and [ __ ] so
it's a weird transition you know what I
mean it's like when you're a kid like
the voices of it is as big a part as
watching it so it just takes a while
like well I gotta be honest with you
like this transition of new announcers
in the NFL really took me a while and
that's why I'm loving Tony Romo because
he's like the greatest like like oh my
god this guy like Tony Romo still in his
30s right like this guy can announce for
like another 30 [ __ ] years in the
level that he knows the game is this is
like it's a great thing you know cuz Al
Michaels I mean how Michaels is gonna be
what like in his 70s you know and just
those voices that I cry I'm so old like
I remember the end of curtain galley
there was Pat Summerall and John Madden
for the longest time Don creaky all of
these guys and just their voice
were just football I wish I could ride
should have looked up some more of him
but what's-his-face he just passed
recently I could see his face used to
host a game show oh my god I'm the
[ __ ] worst the [ __ ] did I forget his
thing I don't know whatever these guys
were all the voices of it so anyway so
now I'm watching a box in here and like
then join the boxing but I'm like these
voices like who the [ __ ] are these
people talking man it's just it's a
weird thing it's like when your favorite
band gets like a new lead singer or
something so unless it's ac/dc somehow
ac/dc was able to do it I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about all
I know is this runs right around the
time when I would start doing
advertising but I don't have any
advertising yet so let's see what else
did I want to talk about maybe I'll
record the advertising after maybe I'll
do something like that
oh I got one for you while watching the
boxing by the way the boxing that's how
old I am
I'm watching boxing and the you know
what's funny is the UFC has so [ __ ]
destroyed this sport [ __ ] destroyed
this sport well they were destroying
themselves with the corruption and
people duck and fights and she's just
bad decisions and all of that basically
throw out my whole [ __ ] life but they
have so destroyed them but you know it's
fun I shouldn't even bring this up oh
it's just funny to me nobody's really
paying attention to it so like when the
ring girls get in the crowd there's
still all these people going Wow [ __ ]
whistling and [ __ ] like a [ __ ] Bugs
Bunny cartoon the only thing they're
doing is not barking like a dog and
stomping their foot on the [ __ ] floor
you know what I mean but as I've always
maintained like when it when it comes to
this getting offended [ __ ] it has to be
something big enough that they'll waste
their time attaching their wagon oh my
god is that [ __ ] is Larry Merchant gone
Larry Merchant I mean Jesus Christ and
he he that guy is like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he there was just certain fighters
you could tell he just [ __ ] hated him
you know and he would never say anything
positive and then he'd go in the ring
and start talking tough like he was
gonna [ __ ] do something but I'll miss
that guy you know he had that get off my
lawn vibe but anyways I was looking at
my my travel schedule for that run that
I have that starts in Iceland and ends
in Israel I have a day off between
wherever the [ __ ] I end and then flying
over to Israel and on that day there's a
MotoGP race in Spain but I just think
it's gonna be too much to try and get to
but I really was gonna try to catch a
[ __ ] race this year I was gonna try
to go to Austin but my schedule is not
working out but I am so [ __ ]
ridiculously excited for Formula One and
MotoGP to start back up again this is
what gets me through it's you know you
get the dog days of summer with baseball
this is like the dog days before I guess
it's really just February now because
March Madness is next month
you know football's [ __ ] over so
March Madness is next month but
basketball and hockey it doesn't really
start [ __ ] mattering until like you
know Jesus Christ the beginning of April
you figuring out who's gonna be what
seed or whatever speaking of which
congratulations the Lakers in the last
second shot beat my [ __ ] Boston
Celtics I don't know what's going on
with the Celtics I got the stupid
[ __ ] or they go out the hardwood
classic package and I've watched like
three Bruins games this year in like
half a Celtics game over Christmas I've
just been so goddamn busy it's killing
me I don't know what's going on all I
know is we have all this talent on the
Celtics and I don't know if we're there
underachieving or what but like I said I
was doing that acting gig last week and
one of the guys on the sets at a what's
up with Kyrie is he gonna go to LA
so just a fact that he was asking that
made me made me a little bit nervous hey
by the way I'm watching this for this
Davis Ruiz fight so I hope that's how
you say his [ __ ] name and if I have a
second I thought it was in Los Angeles I
was like Jesus Christ I could have
[ __ ] gone to that but it's in Carson
City Nevada and I was just thinking
that's one of the few cities I've never
been to you know I've been to I've been
all the A's all the bees and most of the
Seas sea level cities not saying that
your city sucks it's just you know
there's no professional sports team
there you know there's no traffic is a
bit of a meth problem you know you know
the characteristics of a sea city you're
downtown still you can still if you
squint your eyes you're surprised like
Cole Younger and Jesse James aren't
walking up the street it still has that
you know Wild West look about it at
least it does out here cars the city
actually that is the capital of Nevada
and I've never [ __ ] been there a lot
of people if you were to ask them hey
man like what's the capital in Nevada
they would be like well I would have to
say that's Las Vegas and if you said no
they'd be like okay [ __ ] Reno and
you'd be like all right there's no
reason to swear at me but no it's not
Reno and then they might even guess
Laughlin before they would get it you
know where the [ __ ] it is with it Oh
Carson City always just south just south
of Reno
I love Reno I [ __ ] love it
oh there's Lake Tahoe maybe I have been
in I've been to Lake Tahoe Jesus Christ
I just like pass right through Carson
City that even [ __ ] realize it
how the [ __ ] did Carson City end up
being the capital this has got to be
like some sort of gold rush Cowboys [ __ ]
by the way there's a movie out called
the man who killed Hitler and then the
Bigfoot starring Sam Elliot
all right if you don't [ __ ]
immediately try and find out how you can
watch that movie you are no friend of
mine it's about a guy you know the
character he's the guy that found Hitler
and killed him in World War two
and now they're pulling him out of
retirement because the Bigfoot not
Bigfoot the Bigfoot just like I'm
watching the boxing all right he has to
go to Canada and kill the Bigfoot
because evidently Bigfoot is walking
around carrying some sort of plague that
could wipe out human beings so and
evidently I guess Bigfoot is the Hitler
of like a a barnable snowman how do you
say that [ __ ] what I don't know like
what what I don't know of Apes what
[ __ ] world is I mean I look this up
right now this is this is why the feds
will never come and pick me up
they'll never worry no matter how much
conspiracy theory I say that I might be
right about when they just checked my
Google searches here they'll just be
like alright this guy is not a threat
because of this Google search right now
what kind of animal is somebody said Big
Bird Bigfoot I'm one of them the first
one to ever search that what kind of
animal Bigfoot or scoffs watch are said
to be hairy upright walking is it from
any sort of family you know
its own it's like an ape [ __ ] Bill
Walton as as far as I can tell in North
American folklore Bigfoot or Sasquatch
are said to be hairy upright walking
ape-like creatures that dwell in the
wilderness and leave footprints that's
the funny thing about Bigfoot what what
the [ __ ] is the thing ever really done
you know it walks around okay if you
know a sasquatch you got to leave your
footprints all over the [ __ ] place
you know it's always running away
it hasn't really done anything that's
why I love this movie they've somehow
found a reason for a man to finally find
Bigfoot and then kill the [ __ ] thing
all right if I was writing that
screenplay okay
Bigfoot having that [ __ ] you know
carrying the plague and the end you
would find out that it was all [ __ ]
you know that it wasn't really doing
anything it's just where it was walking
around there was a lot of oil underneath
the land where it was walking around so
the government then demonized Bigfoot
and said that it could take down this
entire first world nation because it's
walking around with the [ __ ] widths
Khalid fever
first of all nobody's ever seen Bigfoot
they don't know where the [ __ ] thing
is there's never really been a good
picture of the goddamn thing yet somehow
they know it has the [ __ ] plague all
I know is Sam Elliott's in it and I'm
gonna [ __ ] watch that movie is it in
theaters you know something that can you
[ __ ] him I still can't believe Aquaman
made all that money mate demigod I mean
happy it did him happy some movies
making some [ __ ] money made two
hundred and fifty [ __ ] million
dollars I can't believe people saw that
[ __ ] movie Aquaman he's a superhero
in the ocean a fish don't commit crimes
I know you want
go see it yeah I didn't see that movie
what I would do is if I was writing
Aquaman Aquaman is [ __ ] pissed off
because of that swirl of trash out in
the [ __ ] Pacific Ocean and he's fun
cuz he's not really a person is he right
that should be my next Google search
what kind of fish is Aquaman
what did Aquaman do you know what he is
some pirate [ __ ] a mermaid okay and
that's and then the mermaid gave birth
to Aquaman alright Aquaman grew up
without a dad it's probably a Viking
with his blond hair used to have blond
hair anyways I don't know when I was a
kid he had blond hair and an orange
shirt you know now he looks like the
[ __ ] Undertaker anyways Undertaker's
nephew so anyways if I was right in that
[ __ ] movie alright some Viking bagged
a mermaid Oh whose kid knew historically
speaking probably raped her right so
he's the rape baby of a Viking and a
mermaid alright so his dad's not around
and he's a rapist so there's no reason
to look that guy up plus he's on land
and he has gills he can [ __ ] breathe
underwater
and he sort of speaks through like waves
so I mean it's bad enough he got to try
to [ __ ] you know call up a rapist on
Father's Day now I mean you don't really
speak so how can you communicate with
them and then the mom you know sort of
shuns him because of obviously ouch she
got pregnant so he's just sort of
[ __ ] you know has issues with this
mom definitely doesn't like his dad and
his dad's really the only land dweller
that he knows so he's just like you know
what [ __ ] this man I don't need anybody
I'm just gonna hang in the ocean with my
fish friend all right cuz fish you know
they don't [ __ ] judge them or
anything they take him in like the you
know like the wolves with the babies
that get left out in the woods
alright just just bear with me I'm gonna
get somewhere with this so then the
[ __ ] guy you know as he gets older
and older and older right they
they just sitting there uh all this
trash keeps getting dumped in the ocean
and finally he can't [ __ ] take it
anymore
and he just goes on land and he starts
[ __ ] taking people out like Charles
Bronson and Deathwish all right you know
and like death wish it starts with a
rape alright but in this one he's he's
doing it for the environment and the
first people he kills our hoarders well
I guess hoarders he likes cuz they don't
pull her throat in the ocean you know
what I mean he'd go after all those
people no you know he'd [ __ ] kill he
killed those people that that made that
TV show about being minimalist that
encouraged all these people after they
bought all this [ __ ] to just go down and
dump it at Goodwill and then goodwill
just throws it in the [ __ ] ocean or
whatever the [ __ ] it is they do with it
you know I mean and all the people I
thought I thought he would kill and I
really think about he wouldn't kill I
was thinking that people in storage wars
he killed them he wouldn't those people
taking [ __ ] that usually get thrown out
and they'd [ __ ] buy it and they find
some stupid [ __ ] to buy it I think he
just hangs out at a goodwill and just as
people show up with their garbage bags
of [ __ ] he just [ __ ] takes him and
before the cops can get there right the
cops chase him back to the [ __ ] ocean
you know maybe he goes to that swirl of
trash and he just find [ __ ] and he just
goes through and he finds had dresses I
don't [ __ ] know I'll be honest with
you I don't know what I'm talking about
at this point I'm just telling you how I
would do movies that I never saw I don't
know what the [ __ ] did they do with
Aquaman and then they gave him that
chicken of the sea [ __ ] pitchfork I
didn't understand it
is he mad that we're eating tuna we're
killing all his friends you know if
that's the case he should start in Japan
they're the ones that's doing all the
sushi they started that [ __ ] right see
I'm trying to get it out of my country
alright so there you go now I don't know
where to go from here because now I only
have like a [ __ ]
half hour left I still have to do
advertising and reads you know read your
questions so that's what I'll do on
Monday I'll just bang out the last
twenty five minutes of this this has
been the first half of the podcasts the
ramblings of a lonely man who's in a
hotel room and he wants to call the
front desk but there's no information on
how exactly I'm supposed to [ __ ] do
that but it's a good thing because I was
going to order food and now I'm not
[ __ ] hungry anymore
alright I'm gonna watch this goddamn
fight and through the magic of editing
and time there'll be no delay in your
podcast just know the next time I talk I
don't know where I'll be Sunday on
Monday I don't [ __ ] know what do you
give a [ __ ] right cuz it's gonna be a
half a second delay for you and just
like that now I'm in Los Angeles this is
that amazing isn't that amazing
what an edit can do to you that was one
second for me that was a [ __ ] you
know it's Monday morning I almost feel
like I have to do the intro so much time
has gone by by the way I believe the
last thing I was talking about Saturday
Hey Dude want you [ __ ] come over on
say Saturday say say another card game
that I played Crazy Eights or some
people call it dirty AIDS that's just a
great [ __ ] game and I suddenly
realized you know because I went over
one of my relatives domiciles there and
I'm just [ __ ] I was just walking
around all wound up like I usually am
brain going a mile a minute
can't [ __ ] shut it off you know the
only thing that I found that can shut it
off is copious amounts of alcohol or
sitting down and smoking a cigar neither
of them are good for you but I found
with
if I just sit down there's something
about shuffling the cars handling the
cards gets rid of that energy and I
[ __ ] chill out and then amazingly
enough when I play cards I have to learn
how to control my emotions or else
people know what's in my hand I found it
very therapeutic you know the TV wasn't
on the entire time I was there and I
didn't look at my smartphone and my head
felt clearer so I think I learned so I
think I'm Otto already a scatterbrain
and all the TV screens and phone screens
do not help someone like that doesn't
help someone like me it's my brains like
what about this what about this well
I'll [ __ ] look that up oh is that
what that is
what is this link to Oh what what it
what does so-and-so look like now that
will surprise me you know and then I'm
just [ __ ] there goes two hours of my
life and then I'm laying in bed and I
can't [ __ ] get to sleep so I'm gonna
try to get my wife into playing cards
although I don't think she's gonna do it
because she's inherently a chill person
and I'm worried that if she starts
playing cards she might literally nod
off and fall backwards out of the chair
but anyways old Billy freckles Oh Billy
freckles 79 days no [ __ ] booze and I
gotta admit I am getting [ __ ] done I did
a couple of things that I would never do
I edited two episodes of efforts her
family went through the script and threw
in my punch lines did it on the [ __ ]
plane and there is no way all right when
it's not the off season if I'm playing
if the season is started there is no
[ __ ] way I would have gotten half of
that done I would have sat there on the
plane I would have watched a movie I
would have had one and I'd be like hey I
like this feeling can we enhance it yeah
so I don't know do they have like binge
drinker AAA meetings you know everybody
there's just like bored like
yeah you know I could stop you know I
don't need the [ __ ] you know I don't
know I just maybe it's a place where
they're playing cards or some [ __ ] yeah
bill it's called a casino you know and
you don't have to drink you can make
that choice for yourself you can be
brave you can be a warrior
you'd be all of these [ __ ] things all
right hang on a second
anyways I need to read some of the
advertising here for this week here oh
you know I was coming back from New York
City so I always get the New York Post
that's my thing that I I read the post
and the Daily News but mostly the post
cuz I like the sports section better I
you know I was reading this [ __ ] you
know the Yankees like spring training
starting and it's so [ __ ] funny like
the Yankee mindset which is totally
George Steinbrenner well like we we
haven't won a World Series you know we
lost to the Red Sox so the honeymoon is
over blah blah blah blah blah it's
always though there's always this threat
you know with that whatever manager they
have or whatever there's always this
constant pressure that like they have to
somehow do the impossible which is to
win the way they used to win well
actually they would accept the way they
want in the late 90s but I do respect
that out of that franchise but it's also
funny because it's an empty threat like
what are you gonna stop watching you
know we all know we're not gonna abandon
our teams at least the real fans won all
right LegalZoom everybody LegalZoom if
you're determined to start a business or
secure your family's future in 2019 it's
easy to get distracted by hurdles that
pop up along the way
that's right whatever you just agreed to
that's when you would have done your
[ __ ] will
that's why LegalZoom is here to help but
their network of independent attorneys
their gunslingers that Wildman they're
out there on their own licensed in all
50 states how the [ __ ] do you do that
you gotta take the bar exam 50 times
legal zone can help you navigate your
legal needs well bill once you're a
lawyer you nearly need to mean to fill
out an application won't be our bill
they hired 50 lawyers maybe they did
that one from each state I don't know
from wills and trusts to LLC's
trademarks contract reviews and moolah
LegalZoom has helped more than 4 million
people like you take care of their
responsibilities and the best part is
and you are responsible okay
you bring a life into this world god
damn it they need to get some cash when
you [ __ ] faceplant at a food court
after you put that last piece of orange
chicken and your goddamn piehole and the
best part is LegalZoom is not a law firm
so you won't get charged by the hour
make this year the year you finally do
the right thing for your family I'll
take the steps you need to take for your
small business Legal Zoom is here to
help so you can focus on what you need
to do but what you do best make it make
a difference in your life I hate when I
just all of a sudden can't [ __ ] read
[ __ ] Apple make a difference in your
life this year by visiting legalzoom.com
now and for special savings be sure to
enter promo code bir b you are are in
the referral box at checkout Legal Zoom
where life meets legal that's
legalzoom.com oh man you know what it
went off the rails but I crushed it in
the end
simply safe are you simple and you want
to be safe we have a solution for you so
here's a timely stat stat for you almost
half of us make a new year new year's
resolution every single year we've all
made them
most of us probably broken him not me
man I said it wasn't drinking this year
I'm better than you
happens to the best of us but one
resolution worth sticking to this year
keeping your home and family safe that's
why I recommend simply safe home
security evidently according to the copy
I didn't realize that I recommended it I
thought I'd just read it because they
gave me money over there simply safe is
a 24/7 home security is 24/7 home
security with no contracts or catch
caches they believe the safest place on
earth should be your home so you feel
protected every time you shut your door
and leave for work or shut your eyes at
night how safe does Ted Nugent feel at
home you know he walks around with like
a [ __ ] gun strapped to each leg and a
crossbow around his [ __ ] back more
than three a lot you see somebody shoot
more than 3 million people instead of
leaves you know in his hat he probably
has like wallpaper you know so he blends
in with this house more than 3 million
people already feel this way every day
thanks to simply safe and they're not
the only ones they are not the only ones
with home security
the folks at PC Magazine named simply
safe both editors choice and readers
choice for 2018 well there you go
there's a legit magazine PC Magazine mm
I've never heard of it
2019 feels like a good year to ask
yourself is my home as safe as it could
be and if you're thinking well maybe
this year well if you're thinking well
maybe this year maybe this is the year
to change that [ __ ] call to action get
simply safe and just get simply safe
just go to simply save Burt calm to get
started
that simply safe bird calm to protect
your home and family today simply safe
bird calm Oh Jerry's berries
why you bug in talk about your plans for
Valentine's Day this year what would you
do if you weren't procrastinating I
didn't procrastinate and my wife reached
out to somebody of influence and they
got us a reservation
and a [ __ ] restaurant that we
wouldn't be able to get into if I just
called myself do you know who I am
hello we're going to McDonald's all
right share a personal Valentine's Day
story
what are your must gives you got to get
a Ricard you got to get her some flowers
you gotta you can't just give her the
card and have something that's some
stranger rope for whoever bought the
card you have to add a paragraph of your
own [ __ ] and you have to write that
paragraph out on something else so when
you inevitably have a spelling error or
run out of room or something like that
you don't do it on the card and then you
painstakingly copy it over to the new
card and then you hand it to your wife
she reads it in three seconds and goes
reaches over gives you a nice kiss and
then looks over your shoulder to see if
there's a package in some sort of
heart-shaped wrapping to see if she got
some shiny [ __ ] so she can decide at
what level she's gonna [ __ ] you that
night she gonna go through the motions
is she gonna give you the first three
months of your relationship sex or is
she gonna take it to another level it
all depends on whether or not there's a
tray of sherry berries over your
shoulder when she goes to hug you I mean
come on people do I even need to read
the copy after this I'll do it just as
an exercise in trying to get better on
how to read on reading out loud okay
never go wrong with with their signature
dipped Valentine's strawberries dipped
in milk dark or white chocolate goodness
for
discerning palate she'll fall in love
with every bite stop
top with decadent toppings chocolate
chips heart and glitter sprinkles honey
I have to admit I'm having an emotional
affair with Sherry's berries always
fresh always tasty always worth the wait
perfect companion to a candlelit dinner
a bouquet of flowers or a night on the
town valentine's made easy' arise fresh
with a hundred percent cherries berries
guarantee ships anywhere naturally give
sweet something's to your long-distance
love Valentine's Day is just a few days
away sender of Valentine's Day gift of
her dreams at the price of your dreams
starting at just $19.99 plus shipping
and handling plus order now and make
this Valentine's Day really special by
getting double the berries for just $10
more go to berries calm BER RI es calm
click on the microphone and enter my
code check out that's BR RI es comm
click the microphone and enter code BER
order today
hey what do you do if your if your
girlfriend you know is getting a little
hefty there you don't to get a
chocolate-covered strawberries can you
just get her the strawberries
do they have an ala carte strawberry
maybe a a chocolate-covered Brussels
sprout
stamps.com stamps.com it's the fastest
and more convenient way to get postage
you'll be hilarious is if your
girlfriend got you Rogaine for [ __ ]
Valentine's Day simply use your computer
to print official US postage for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send and the mail
carrier picks it up no more lugging the
mail to the post office you know heavy
envelopes are no more hassles man with
stamps calm you get discounted postage
rates that you can't even get at the
post office not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters and there's no equipment
to lease and no long term commitments I
use stamps come anytime I sent out my
posters I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] if I can do
it oh can you
and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes our four-week trial plus
postage and a digital stay out scale so
start the new year off right go to
stamps.com click on the microphone atop
the homepage and type in bird that
stamps comm enter ber alright now let's
get to let's [ __ ] read them Mayo
let's [ __ ] read the mail alright from
reddit Los Angeles then and now follow
up I love that someone gave me this here
because I'm gonna go back to reading
books now like I read a lot of them but
like I really think that my brain does
not do well watching a bunch of shows
and screens and stuff it's just I find
I'm gonna go I'm gonna do some old
people's [ __ ] I'm gonna play cards I'm
gonna complain to the local my local
representative about the sidewalk having
a crack in it whatever the [ __ ] old
people do paint or whatever I'm gonna
read some books we'll see there are a
lot of my my favorite things to do those
with Reader's Digest is to read the
awful jokes to my wife and I know that
that's a Jim Norton bit back from the
Opie and Anthony show but I feel like if
I do it in my bedroom I'm not stealing
from him maybe I'll give him credit next
time he used to read that the comics was
one of my favorite bits that he would do
then the local newspaper daily comic
sorry there are a lot of books on Los
Angeles history this person writes I
find the whole the whole thing
fascinating even thought it's history
even though it even thought even though
personal thought even though its history
isn't as long as Boston filling in New
York the whole thing is fascinating
let me see they said I made an album
I'll just go to the page I would like to
see this let's see oh yeah look at the
old all my goodness look at these old
houses holy [ __ ] they just knocked all
of this [ __ ] down didn't they
how many times must they plow it [ __ ]
over you know a lot of old houses they
just had that creepy [ __ ] look but
these are incredible and you know what I
just realized you guys can't see him all
right let's get back to whatever the
[ __ ] it was I was reading that
highlights just how okay I'm at an album
that highlights just how true bills
bulldoze everything is la destroyed an
entire historic neighborhood downtown to
force the poor from the city center and
build more economically viable
skyscrapers one of the darkest blemishes
in LA's history and that's not the old
thats not the only one the amount of
neighborhoods destroyed and people
displaced due to freeway construction is
astronomic it is estimated 300,000
people were displaced between 1940 and
1974 the freeways which pretty much
destroyed the history this historic city
it explains why LA is more suburban than
cities like San Francisco yeah it's
fascinating how they do a lot of stuff
you know those eminent domain which
means well we're building this freeway
you can take this money for your house
or we'll just [ __ ] take it from you I
try not to get too sad about it I just
look at it like you know when those
historic neighborhoods were being built
there was Native Americans crying going
you know we used to [ __ ] sit there
and I don't know she's getting a buffalo
whatever the [ __ ] I don't I don't
know what the [ __ ] you know there's
always gonna be somebody that you know
you know what used to be there so I
don't know get a deck of cards and shut
off your [ __ ] TV and maybe you can
have a nice 20 minutes to yourself all
right
advice from Mormon at BYU hey there
Billy nicknamed last week on your
podcast you read a letter from a Mormon
attending BYU asking for advice about
leaving the church as a former Mormon
that's a great form of Mormon hi I'm
Mike Mormon I'm a former Mormon keep it
going for the former Mormon who also
grew up in Utah I thought I could only
offer a little advice for them I thought
I could offer a little advice for them I
all
so went through something similar when I
was 19 I told my parents I wasn't gonna
go on a mission which is a huge rite of
passage in the Mormon religion oh my god
they must have been crushed and then you
got to deal with upsetting the two
people that you want the most approval
approval from they were really upset
about it and it was hard for me to do
but I couldn't lie to myself anymore and
try to believe in what the Church
teaches not long after that I moved out
of my parents house and started
attending the University of Utah in Salt
Lake City
it seemed daunting at the time and I
didn't know I didn't think I would be
able to afford it but somehow is able to
do it good for you the hardest part
about leaving the church is that all
that the other members will ask you a
million questions about why you're
leaving and they're always trying to
convince you to come back obviously you
can't shut out your family completely
but if you don't believe in what the
Church teaches then you're not doing
yourself any favors by staying just
because it's routine take it from me I
left the church a long time ago and I
don't regret it the people I know who
have regrets other ones I went to high
school with stay in the church went on
missions got married in the temple and
ended up leaving Mormonism anyway they
all say that they would do things
differently if they had to do it over
again the Mormon Church isn't going
anywhere it will always be there if you
eventually decided to go back decide to
go back but you'll never get your time
back if you decide to stay in the church
and then end up regretting it I hope
this helps and I'm sure you'll meet
people who feel the exact same way you
do I've met tons of them and they really
helped me out anyways as always thanks
and go hug yourself Wow
yeah I imagine if you know if you looked
for some sort of support group online
you could probably find a way to do that
and I like what he said the church is
always going to be there you can always
come back you know or you know maybe if
you enjoyed as much as this guy doesn't
you stay out there you go it's your life
you choose all right advice from Mormon
here we goes another one
dear Billy ba ba l ba al look it up all
right what is this Mormon football bag
let's see be a AL Mormon word how many
time Bob
and all right what the [ __ ] is this this
is some deep religious [ __ ] here Bible
dictionary be a al possessor Lord the
Sun God and the male or generative
principle in nature he was worshipped
with different ideas and rites in
different places so it's a possessor
Lord the [ __ ] is a possessor Lord is
that a landlord for Jesus I don't I
don't even know what that means think
this is why I why I just try to keep my
life simple because even if I don't know
a word if I look it up I still don't
know the word all I'm left with is more
questions just wanted to chime in on the
advice that she gave that kid at BYU
okay good because I didn't think I gave
him good advice I had no idea what I
whatever I grew up Catholic on the East
Coast and converted to Mormonism when I
was 18 then a year later I left my top
20 college to serve a mission in Las
Vegas you went to Las Vegas to try and
convert people Jesus Christ you dobin
with both feet can I just talk to you
for a second about Mormonism some guys
sitting at a blackjack table he's on a
roll or even worse he's [ __ ] losing
when I got back my school wouldn't take
me I was in a music program for drums
and hadn't practiced in two years so I
had hoped to go to BYU for a year and
build my chops back up before I could
get back into my original program wait a
minute what do you mean wait wait would
have [ __ ] as your school not take you
I was a grew up Catholic you converted
Mormonism he left you top 20 college to
serve a mission in Las Vegas when I got
back my school wouldn't take me oh so I
had to go to BYU for a year and build my
chops back up before I could get back
into my original program Oh cuz you even
played drums in two years all right I
got married in the church because my
parents were members they couldn't go to
the ceremony in the temple what we did
have a
ring ceremony for all my friends and
family as the marriage in the temple is
usually small with a little pomp and
circumstance I can't think of anything
there hurt that has hurt my parents as
much as the decision that I have made
surrounding my beliefs the long talks
the arguments the crying the pain of not
being around their son etc it was very
hard on my family through all of that
though they want me to be happy and want
me to be me we are closer now than we
have ever been having worked through our
differences your parents should always
love and support you well it depends on
what you're doing you know if you're
gonna go rob a liquor store shoot some
heroin I don't think they should love
and support well they could say no while
I was at BYU there was a student in my
program that took his life because he
didn't like the lifestyle of the church
and was scared of what his parents would
think oh my god I haven't spoken to his
parents after his death they would
rather have their son alive and out of
the church than dead and in the church
Wow it will be hard but don't ever feel
like there is no way out and no way that
and no one that has your back BYU can
make you feel that way begin to talk
with your parents about it now and share
how you feel about yourself they will be
hurt but still love you eat a dick bill
get some meat on those bones you skinny
[ __ ] my love on it you know if I'm fat
I'm fat if I'm skinny I'm too skinny I
just can't make you people I'm all right
what do we got here from a masculine
lesbian lady oh I put it out there you
know Valentine's Day was coming up you
know is coming up you know the pressure
is always on the guy and we have to show
how much we love them and they really
don't have to do [ __ ] other than put on
something hot and bang you and they act
like they're doing you a favor when sex
feels good to them too so I don't really
don't understand you know can you
imagine if I acted like you know banging
my wife was was this great pleasure
thing for her as I'm on top of her like
that like
I'm not having a good time and those are
the noises I make during sex and you can
[ __ ] deal with that for the rest of
the day have that in your head that's
what I do on a loop on a loop from a
masculine so I asked you know I want to
talk to the man in the less than with a
more manly woman in the lesbian
relationship because what does she have
to do you know cuz there's two ladies
there right now do you both the man [ __ ]
or there's one you know the one who has
to go up on the [ __ ] roof during the
rain to fix the [ __ ] you know you
goddamn the the [ __ ] satellite dish
right so anyways hey yo I can't Billy
Bibbit City the Basset e I got another
word I have to look up I have no idea
what do you guys wear do you guys hear
these [ __ ] words I know I can't spell
I know I'm [ __ ] stupid
now capacity usually uncountable the
practice our habit of drinking too much
alcohol oh my god I love this word how
do you pronounce it pronunciation is it
boo Basset e-beam answer me how do you
say it velocity velocity so you say but
as a day all right a yo Billy Bob acity
Wow visit this this person to think
although I think you are back on the
wagon of of late yes I am I've been a
fan of yours wait am I gonna look that
word up again with I already forget what
it means booze huh right opacity the
practice our habit of drinking too much
alcohol
somebody who boozes that's a great name
for a band it's a great name for a
podcast Billy Bob acity I don't know if
you can beat that that's a great
wrestling character he's drunk he can't
hear the ref I have been a fan of yours
going on a decade now you're literally
my favorite comedian all the way back to
you punching the muffins in the at the
flea market
my flippin favorite god bless you you
put out the call for a masculine lesbian
lay too right so here's your earful
first off I have no idea what it's like
to be a man all I know is that I can
relate to so many of your jokes and
rants about the dynamics between men and
women from the man side it's a
refreshing to hear a woman say she
actually doesn't know what it's like to
be a man so many of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] I know exactly what it's like
it's easier either you're a cartoon
character I've been married to my lovely
wife for 21 years the first nine
illegally until same-sex marriage became
legal in Massachusetts when we legalized
our vows congratulations in our
relationship I am the breadwinner the
fixer of all broken things the killer of
scary bugs for sure the one who would
have to climb on the roof and fix the
damn antenna in the rain barring that
the one that's got to negotiate with the
servicemen while she nudges me and says
just pay him I'm missing my show the one
who pays for dinner
even when I'm the celebrated the list
goes on
oh my god Jesus Christ could I have a
beer with you further I am expected to
ensure my lovely wife is wowed on
Valentine's Day our anniversary and her
birthday I make good money don't get me
wrong but my gosh I like that you
already said flipping and my gosh are
you a card player deep lake old lady
cards Crazy Eights what the hell am I I
ended oh my gosh in fairness she puts up
with my mercurial attitude
circular debating an occasional raging
wait is somebody trolling me right now
is this the lesbian version of me still
I have no but I don't say m'gosh still I
have no doubt that I would be cut in
half if we divorced also no doubt she'll
outlive me while being such a brave
widow lol before I get all Rodney
Dangerfield on you no respect they'll
tell you no respect at all in truth we
are the best of friends all the way back
to our first day in high school she
understands me more than anyone in my
life and has truly helped pushed me
forward in my career in ways I never
thought possible
win-win scene I was a man I don't think
I could ever admit that about my wife
maybe that's the flaw she's funny
without trying and brilliantly smart and
honest she helps me be a better person
wait did Nia write this and she's
pretending to be a lesbian as a woman of
a certain age 49
I came up at a time when dynamics
between same-sex relationship and had
the male-female polarity expectation
attached I don't think it's as much that
way now so much has changed in the LGBTQ
culture since we were coming up lesbian
gay bi trans queer and I don't know [ __ ]
I kidding I mean it's something else I
have to look up I can never remember how
that goes LGBTQ then back then
old man voice burger boy day the term
butch femme was hugely popular and I am
definitely more butch it's also a
regional identity associated more with
the East Coast and the West
we've lived out west for over a decade
and don't see a whole lot of butch
/femme I don't know but for that matter
we're not nearly as social as we were
back east so who knows you should
totally do a study on Butch's we are we
are a good lot I hope that helps and go
[ __ ] yourself - do you realize how
[ __ ] hilarious it was it would be in
a perfect world you went into a bar
after having a fight with your wife and
some
dude in the lesbian relationship sort of
old-school chick was sitting there at
the bar and you both [ __ ] hit it off
be [ __ ] hilarious
I think that's just how it is I just
think in maybe all relationships this
just there's the person that's [ __ ]
pulling the wagon and then there's a
person sitting in the wagon complaining
you know but when you stop the wagon you
know they rub your back I don't I don't
[ __ ] know any dilemma dear Billy for
in the road is it supposed to be fork in
the road that's fo our dear Billy for in
the road if you had to choose between I
think it's fork in the road if you had
to choose between being president of the
United States or Pope of the Catholic
Church which would you choose and why
o president because that only would have
to make evil decisions for at most eight
years and at the least four years that's
why I would do it they're both
absolutely horrific jobs and the amount
of blood on your hands at the end of it
is I don't think it's something you ever
get past if you're a truly normal human
being and I don't but that's why I don't
think normal human beings go for their
job go for those jobs alright
and there's a lot of people you know
especially in politics they put on the
[ __ ] white hat and they act like
they're there for you some of them are
but they're always there always now
labeled as socialists and working for
you know Isis or the Russians or
whatever and they just get buried
you know I don't know you watched you
watch that that young woman there that
29 year old woman who everybody's just
flipping out about for whatever reason
because she's young and pretty I don't
know why everybody's freaking out about
her she has very little experience and
everybody is freaking out like she's
[ __ ] amazing me one of the things
that she wanted to do was tack certain
Americans 70 percent and it's just like
taxing anybody
more than 50% is [ __ ] criminal the
fact that you're doing the job you
actually get up and do the job and then
somebody who didn't do the job gets more
[ __ ] money than that his [ __ ]
criminal and watching this woman just
sitting there you know talking to these
old politicians and acting like she's
sitting there with a two-by-four and is
gonna start cleaning [ __ ] up and she's
completely ignoring the 800 billion
dollar gorilla in the room completely
[ __ ] ignoring it okay and she's gonna
you what you watch all her righteousness
and all her [ __ ] [ __ ] I guarantee
you guess who's gonna be a
multi-millionaire at the end of her
political career even if she doesn't
advance past the senator House of
Representative level where she only
makes six figures a year guess who's
gonna be a multi-millionaire signing
massive book deal totally [ __ ]
sellout and buy a big-ass [ __ ] house
and maybe do an arena tour like Michelle
Obama or going a speaking tour like
every other [ __ ] president you watch
and go they ain't gonna talk to you
they're gonna go out and talk to banks
in corporations and everyone who
financed their [ __ ] campaigns you
[ __ ] watch all right
you saw what happened when Trump tried
to pull the troops out of Syria both
Democrats and Republicans were 100%
against that and they act like we can't
just we've already displaced all these
people but the but they don't give a
[ __ ] that's their money that money for
being in that [ __ ] [ __ ] over
there that [ __ ] [ __ ] right there is
what makes them [ __ ] millionaires
multi-multi [ __ ] millionaires and all
they do is sit there and blame each
other and every mouth-breathing [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] just believes it drinks
the kool-aid and then goes on Facebook
and starts arguing with each other and
then starts advocating to tax a fellow
American who didn't get us into those
wars upwards of 70 [ __ ] percent
that's the direction we're gonna go in
and it no and at no point are we ever
going to
Zaman the banking system or are we gonna
look at corporations and see how they
can be reeled back into actually being
less powerful than the United States
government or whatever country that
they're in all right that's the world
you enter as president or Pope Pope with
a Catholic Church - Catholic [ __ ]
Church I mean I mean then one of the
biggest [ __ ] terrorist organizations
ever ever the amount of [ __ ] people
that they tortured and murdered I mean
they were in bed with the Nazis they
were hiding one of the Nazis in their
[ __ ] churches one of the guys one of
the [ __ ] people part of the final
solution that the Mossad was hunting
down was found in a [ __ ] Catholic
Church in the South of France dead
Jewish people's gold they had some of
that in the church and they had to
[ __ ] give that back I mean it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] shop so if you get there
that is a lifetime appointment and if
you think you're gonna go in there and
change that when everybody else in their
previous to you has all that blood on
their hands like they're not going to
view you as a threat yeah that was what
was funny when Trump came in he's like
I'm gonna clean up the swamp let's just
say he actually did have a good heart
and he wasn't like the [ __ ] Grinch
let's just say he actually did have a
good heart that whole thing I'm gonna
clean up the swamp like everybody there
who was corrupt was gonna be like well I
guess the party's over he's going to
clean it up no one's gonna work with you
no one's gonna help you cut their own
[ __ ] head off
so I don't know I don't want to enter in
a depressing note but like that is it is
a massive massive massive [ __ ]
problem it's the reason why there's
global warming it's the reason of
overpopulation all of it goes back to
corrupt politician and religion and
that's as far as I can tell and I'm not
a smart guy you might know it better
than me but there is no [ __ ] reason
why
I we shouldn't be polluting much less I
was just reading something where like
the continent of Africa is gonna feel
the effects the first which is the worst
[ __ ] continent for that to happen to
because with racism and third way people
view so-called third world countries and
everything nobody's gonna give a [ __ ]
until it's in their [ __ ] backyard and
it's gonna be [ __ ] too late so there
you go there's one to grow on
and that's why I [ __ ] have gone back
to reading Reader's Digest looking at
those dumb jokes just playing cards and
sitting on my back porch smoking a cigar
staring at a [ __ ] tree because we're
on a runaway [ __ ] train and everybody
and everybody who's a passenger on the
train is blaming everybody else on the
other side of the aisle as if they're
the ones driving the [ __ ] train oh my
god this is depressing anyways that's
the podcast god bless you it's almost
baseball season take me out to the
ballgame I just realized the volume was
up super loud because I just took this
mixer out of my luggage I hope this
wasn't too distorted god bless you I'll
check in on you on Thursday your [ __ ]